garantir la stabilité politique et
financière voilà pourquoi michel fourré
maire de sens depuis six mois la
démission de daniel parisse est candidat
à sa propre succession
élu en 2008 sur la même liste que
l'ancien maire l'adjoint devenu ensuite
dissident a pourtant lui-même poussé
donné le pari ça la sortie les gens ont
bien compris qu'on a essayé de changer
la ville
on a essayé d'arrêter ses
investissements pharaoniques et et qu'on
a qu'on a voulu remettre les finances en
bon état je pense que c'est ça en plus
c'est devenu plus apaisé la ville
on a essayé de calmer le jeu elle aussi
démissionnaire il ya six mois francis
d'externes pharmacienne de profession a
décidé de partir à la conquête de la
ville mais sans aucune étiquette
politique fidèle de daniel paris c'est
jusqu'à la dernière heure elle assume
pleinement ce soutien mais veut
désormais à regarder devant
ça n'est ni abonné ni un héritage
particulier apporté j'ai fait partie de
cette municipalité j'ai assumé les
engagements qui étaient les miens avec
loyauté et détermination jusqu'au bout
aujourd'hui je suis parti dans un autre
engagement qui celui de conduire la
politique de la ville pendant les six
prochaines années
je le fais en dehors des clivages
politiques autre femme candidate à la
mairie claude vivid revendiquer
centriste cette chef d'entreprise est
aussi adjointe depuis six mois au maire
divers gauche michel fourré conséquence
elle n'a pas reçu l'investiture de son
parti
oui j'étais dans l'opposition avec la
droite
j'ai été avant dans l'opposition contre
la droite mais là on a une droite un peu
particulier à 100 ça on a une droite qui
est quand même très droite buisson donc
quand on a une idéale centriste un idéal
humaniste
on n'est pas tellement proche des idées
de cuisson quant à la gauche
on a une gauche qui n'a jamais de
d'ancrage vraiment stable ici à samson a
plutôt une société civile qui est
centriste
pascal simon lui le candidat du ps et du
pc ingénieur dans le civil il croit aux
chances d'une liste de gauche à sens et
veut en finir avec ses mandatures qui
ont selon lui abîmer la ville et ses
habitants
daniel paris son équipe et tous ceux qui
sortent de cette équipe ont plombé la
gauche cenonnaise on est en train de le
reconstruire et on a deux missions on va
on va être élu nous en sommes absolument
convaincus de notre début de campagne le
prouve
mais surtout on est en train de
reconstruire et gauche sénonais c'est à
dire que les dégâts qui ont été faits
par daniel parisse et son équipe sont
réellement profond à la demande des ces
données pour sauver la ville marie
louise fort a elle aussi choisi de faire
campagne
aujourd'hui députée la candidate ump a
déjà été maire de sens les 2001 à 2008
avant de laisser son fauteuil
daniel paris le seul échec de ma
carrière politique ça a été
effectivement en 2008 après une période
difficile relevé la ville d'une faillite
avérée
c'était pas aisée l'art bon c'est une
ville très endormies sans gouvernance
sans gouvernail mais voilà le challenge
est intéressant faut savoir relever les
challenges leur venue du front national
à sens edouard ferrand en est persuadé
sa liste va s'imposer et lui se voit
déjà maire de la commune
face aux nombreuses candidatures et au
ras-le-bol des électeurs le parti de
marine le pen incarnerait un changement
radical il ya eu lieu sur les 4
dernières mandatures quatre couleurs
politiques différentes et les sénonais
sont un petit peu lassé de ces
magouilles de ces bagarres entre entre
élus et je pense qu'ils ont envie d'un
véritable changement et pas les seuls
qui n'ont pas encore été aux décisions à
la mairie de sens et front national avec
trois hommes et trois femmes ils sont
donc six ans tous à sens à partir à
l'assaut de l'hôtel de ville
tout se voit évidemment au second tour
et paris sur la volonté de changement
des sénonais reste à savoir si les
électeurs se déplaceront ou pas dès le
premier tour le 23 mars prochain